hey few and my name is Patrick I'm from
Belfast Northern Ireland oh Patrick and
this man is dressed up he gots on a nice
kind of a robe or something like a
yellow kind of golden ribbon around his
neck or something around his chest kind
of so he looks like a dang like he just
he looks like somebody won him in a
prize in a contest but this is Patrick
from Northern Ireland and that's uh The
Pogues country I think
um Shane McGowan and uh
and onward thank you for calling Patrick
I'm staying at home today applying for
jobs in my Batman dressing gown um
the pasture has been a bit of a struggle
through one thing another and I felt
pretty
hardened tip after depression and lost a
lot of confidence in myself
originally I have to take a bit of a
demotion and work which is uh it's a
better first for me
uh thank you for calling Patrick I can
imagine that that that that's tough
taking a demotion oh man I can feel that
because you probably feel
you know if you especially if you were
thinking kind of you know decent of
yourself than to feel like oh that other
people don't think that you're capable
or that they don't think that you're
moving forward
um that's got to be pretty tough man I
appreciate you sharing that onward I'm
having Pride a little bit
um but I feel that could be a bit of a
blessing because I feel that my
depression has been caused in part by I
need to help people and not on my
current line of work which is finance
and oh wow
yeah man you know what's so funny is
that I'll tell you the greatest day I
ever had in my life and I appreciate you
saying this Patrick the need to help
people the greatest day that I've ever
had in my whole life
I was um in India and I was working with
a group and we were doing some um
we went to a school for disabled
children
and we a storm had come and really
damaged the place and a lot of stuff was
all over the ground in this one area
like a lot of just heavy pieces of
construction and all that it
and we spend the day just clearing off
their playground like and it was hard
work and it was long work and we took
breaks and like spent time with these
kids and uh
and yeah man at the end of that day I
felt
I felt like a human being
I felt undeniably that this is what the
world is about
um onward I was just wondering if you
can make any suggestions as to how I can
stay focused on looking for jobs and
avoiding procrastination because I'm
writing about problem solving one minute
and then I'm watching a face being
carved diet parmesan Facebook the next
I'm writing about problem solving one
minute and then I'm watching a a face
being carved out of Parmesan the next
minute
um and Parmesan is a cheese it's not a
serial killer or nothing that's
hilarious bro I appreciate you I
appreciate this
um
you know what you can do I'll tell you
this point blank I'm looking at you
right now you're a happy guy
um you just made me laugh
one thing you can do is continue to
interact with others that's what you can
do
keep interacting get out there walk
around meet people go to the library I
don't care go to the coffee shop say hey
to people
find other people that have law that
have had a demotion find anybody anybody
because you just made me laugh you can
do that to somebody else
that's it so you need to interact with
others man you need to interact with
others and that's it that's exactly what
you can do and I promise you
that good things are going to happen to
you
I promise you a million percent
now you go out and you put one foot in
front of the other take action you have
to take action you cannot there's no you
will know you will nothing will get
better if you just stay where you are
if you just stay you know when you get
in a tough moment it's like you can take
some breaks you can enjoy Facebook you
can do this or that but you need to take
it you need to stay moving stay in
motion
stay in motion keep it cruising let's
hear a little more from you
and I love listening to the podcast uh
it's really down there hilarious it's a
place where people can actually learn
something like I remember who said it
maybe it was Jordan Peterson and but
people are being like stars of
authenticity and which is podcasts have
some buckets fun so I just want to say a
big shout out to my cousin uh Tammy um I
met James a hero both uh big fans of the
podcast along with me so keep the good
work and thanks very much man
cheers brother uh thank you for calling
man cheers to you up in Northern Belfast
dude I want to go to over there doesn't
it sound cool being in Ireland
man it's so cool
you know I think especially having a
country where it seemed like there's
still a lot of like
you know
Country Pride you know pride in your
country or like you you know to me your
voice to me obviously your voice sounds
unique even though in your country it
probably sounds normal uh to me it
sounds rare because it's a different
sound than I'm used to a different
octave and a different you know the
Irish accent or Belfast accent
um
excuse me but yeah it's uh it seemed
like yeah just nice to hear like an it's
like
yeah I picture you guys being in Ireland
and you know
riding around on like little
you know Irish ponies and stuff and the
ponies have been drinking at the bar and
so they're late
and your cars are just standing outside
and you're angry
you know and you're like whoa where's
the horsies
and um and the horses finally show up
but they're late because they've been
drinking
you know and they've been watching the
footy on telly
and um
and finally you guys get on the horses
or the ponies they're actually ponies
and you just go right back to the bar
and I'm like that's awesome dude
um but I appreciate you guys support I
appreciate the nice words uh but that's
what you can do just stay busy you know
at the end there you mentioned to your
friends it's like you're not thinking
about yourself you're gonna be fine
you know you just stay busy and keep
thinking about others dude and you're
gonna do great
but stay active in it and we can't get
caught up in it you know it's like we
have to be careful when we are doing
stuff that we don't even when we start
to do stuff that we don't think it's
about us and we stay true to we've we
make sure that we touch in base with our
Roots we make sure that we find people
who we can connect with
um
and ask for help
you know even if we're just asking for
help to like just make sure that we're
hey am I doing this okay do I seem okay
you know
maybe ask somebody do you know that I
love you like
when was the last time you asked like
you know
I remember one thing that makes me sad
sometimes I'm not sad but like I I when
I was really struggling with like having
like any feelings like I used to like
really struggle with having like any
emotions at all I would have a ton of
thoughts
but having emotions and I didn't know
who I was I didn't know it all I knew
I'd been alive and I and I knew you know
had a lot of experiences
and I remembered many of them just like
anyone else but I didn't know who I was
and I used to ask my best friend I'd be
like who am I like do you have any
or one of my best friends just how who
am I can tell me anything about myself
um because I was so out of touch with my
feelings you know your feelings are
really where you learn Who You Are uh
and if we're fortunate enough to really
you know
really connect with other people I think
we'll find that we'll probably get
or a good person
you know that we mean well
um but yeah look I appreciate it man I
appreciate you checking in Patrick and
if I had a [__] job I'd give it to
you
you know I don't know what I'd do for uh
if they have a Belfast person but I
would give you a job man
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one